اذا بعد متول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه الجنائيه في
منهاتن امس وجهت الترامب لائحه اتهامات من
اربعه وثلاثين بندا دفع الاخير ببراءته
منها جميعا قبل ان يغادر قاعه المحكمه بعد
انتهاء الجلسه الا ان هناك مفقودات وفقا
لتقرير نشرته صحيفه
فما هو المفقود اذا في لائحه اتهام ترامب
المدعي العام يقول ان الرئيس السابق قام
مرارا وتكرارا بتزوير سجلات تجاريه من
الدرجه الاولى وايضا هناك تهمه رئيسيه
اخرى تتعلق بشراء صمت صمت ب130 الف دولار
دفعها مساعد ترامب السابق مايكل كوهان
لاسكات ستور ميدانييلز بشان علاقتها
المزعومه مع الرئيس الا انها جميعها تهم
فرديه فالسؤال الكبير الذي بقي دون اجابه
هو اين هي الجريمه الثانيه فتزوير السجلات
التجاريه يعد جنحه في نيويورك لان ترامب
استعان للسداد بيكهه فما الجريمه الاخرى
التي يزعم انه يحاول التستر عليها كانت
النظريه الرئيسيه التي تم طرحها الثلاثاء
هي ان السيد براج يدعي بان ترامب قام
بانتهاك قوانين تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
الا ان كهان اعترف فعلا بما قام به ما جعل
الامر غير قابل للنقاش